all right let me just bring a little bit  of breaking news that's coming into us  here at sky news and uh this will touch  many of us actually the author  administrator raymond briggs best known  for creating the snowman which we'll  remember from  christmases throughout our childhood has  passed away he's died at the age of 88  the family have released a statement  saying that we know that raymond's books  were loved by and touched millions of  people around the world  who will be sad to hear this news um the  drawings from fans especially children's  drawings inspired by his books were  treasured by raymond and pinned up on  all of his studio um it said that he had  died um  in the past today at the age of 88 of  course the snowman was released in 1978  as i said was a integral part of many of  our christmases so raymond briggs  the illustrator has died